well i in my intro i invoked uh ruby
rich's new queer cinema and what
what was your perspective on that i mean
that i mean this was right
at the
beginning of that really i i think that
i was i was a little older
and i was maybe part of it in the same
way that you know i was between say
derek german and
gregoraki and todd haynes um i was in
the middle and so i don't know if i mean
all of us particularly derek um were
like students of experimental film like
we would i would go to lacma all the
time and and watch as many
evenings of experimental cinema as i
could or when i was in new york at the
anthology film archives
um and derek obviously
was very influenced by
by that that period in the 60s
um and then later as well or earlier 50s
and 40s and late and
going on into the 70s but um
um i think the new queer cinema was
maybe
the next generation i always felt but i
guess it's still queer in its way
and um
one maybe you're not as militant
as
as maybe
they might have been
but one of the
as i understand it one of the things
that did change a bit in the course of
production was
whether or not
both
mike and scott were gay characters right
oh yeah that's a um they weren't
actually um in the original screenplay
they were
they were straight street hustlers who
um did things for money
and when uh
river arrived
uh from his his um film that he had done
in seattle called dogfight a nancy
savoka film he had brought with him is
nancy savoka one of her
people in the art department was from
act up
matt ebert and so matt was you know very
close to river and he says your
character has to be gay you have to be
gay
you know promise me and so there was a
request
by them because it wasn't really
part of it part of i think the inc
congruity of their lives was that they
weren't
homosexual they were
heterosexual doing homosexual things
um
and i thought but i see you know i see
the value and yes you can totally there
are gay hustlers and you can be one
so that was that was a sort of a pushing
from matt everett to push his character
into like a gay character who had a
crush on
his friend scott
i mean it does add a whole different
dimension in a way i mean it's kind of
the dimension of of love right so yeah
i feel like the film wouldn't be the
same without i think he was right more
bleak yeah probably
and it's a pretty bleak film anyway